she's like still like how do i work this
app
and she feels really weird being on it
and i'm like
trust me everyone wants you to be on
this app i promise
okay miss tulip how does it feel to be
unmasked
voila here you are oh my gosh i've been
keeping this a secret for so long
and when i tell you it was the hardest
thing i've ever done
i wanted to tell my friends so bad
i wanted to tell all of my fans but i'm
so glad that it's finally out in the
open
social media
did you tell anybody who knew my mom and
my sister were the only people that knew
which was crazy to me because i've never
done something like that
why was this a show that you wanted to
do because we were kind of excited to
see you under that that mask
yeah i mean i have always loved matt
singer
i've watched it from season one and i
thought it was the coolest show
and when they reached out to me i was
like oh my god this is the coolest thing
because also i thought it would be
really fun for me to do because
i feel like it helped me gain confidence
and you know i got to be whoever i
wanted to be and i thought it was just
you know
so fun to just play someone different
you were probably one of the toughest
ones i believe but ashley had it
so when you when you heard her say your
name like
boom it's this is who it is like were
you freaking out
i was definitely freaking out i was like
i didn't want to get guests but
apparently a lot of people already got
you know guests during the season so i
felt really good about it but
no i did not expect anyone to get it
which i'm like
super happy that ashley did because i
love her and i've been
i've loved her since high school musical
so
so um max came in third as the sloth
gabby douglas is first as cotton candy
um you know when you saw them and like
were you surprised that it was
it was those two well actually what
people
don't know is i actually didn't know who
was in the finale with me
until yesterday when i was in an
interview and they told
me um because obviously i'm the youngest
one
there so i had to leave as soon as i got
called because of my pumpkin
so i literally my mom and i were like
who do who was it like we don't even
know
and your pumpkin for people who don't
know is there's a certain number of
hours you could work
at your age yes yes
i got you so okay how difficult was it
dancing
in that costume i know max was saying
like his fur was so thick i think it was
like
40 pounds or something like that how
difficult was it for you and the tool
for me the body was really easy to dance
in because obviously i've been dancing
in great dance competitions forever
so that was pretty easy but the first
time i had a fitting
for it i put the head on and i was
actually running into walls
like it was it was so hard to see i was
like freaking out i was like i there's
no way i'm gonna be able to dance in
this
and as soon as i you know went on stage
for the first time i was like oh this
isn't so bad
um but it was definitely sometimes i
would get really stressed out because i
was like
i feel like i'm not gonna be able to see
when i get off stage now obviously we
know you're a dancer we saw you on dance
moms
did you have any hand in the
choreography
at all or were you just like i just want
to come in and dance i'm not
doing anything okay yeah i just wanted
to come in and you know just
let them do what they what their job is
obviously and
they did great all of the choreographers
were so amazing and i had the best dance
partner as well
um his name is teddy and i he helped me
step out of my comfort zone i was so
nervous about it
and he made me just feel so safe so it
was really amazing
so your sister uh maddie knew you said
um did she give you any tips or was she
like
you know she's never done it of course
but was she any help at all
she just said to have fun i definitely
think i was worrying about it too much
but at the end of the day it was really
just a fun competition and everyone is a
winner
um so yeah i mean i thought it was very
different from any other
dance competition that i've done because
every week we would just get uplifted by
the judges it was just all
you know very amazing to
be in that environment because i was
just always feeling so good about myself
and
i think everyone else can say that as
well that was in the competition
did dancing with the stars juniors
prepare you for this at all
a hundred percent yeah um i mean yes
i've done dance competitions like i said
but
it's you know an actual competition show
and it was
definitely harder than i expected you
have to learn dances super fast every
single week and
i mean obviously i'm used to that but it
was way
more hard because you know i was doing a
different style every single week i was
learning
polka i would have to dance in a huge
head
so like um it was definitely a challenge
but i think it was
the most fun experience for me so yeah
how did these dances because like i said
we do know you from dance moms how do
these dances compare to what you did
on there and and you know on that show
dancing with the stars was all ballroom
which was
something i've never done before and it
was so fun to learn because i've always
wanted to learn it
and also i was against all younger kids
so i was the oldest one on the show i
was
14 at the time and everyone else was 9
10 11 so it was definitely a different
experience for me
because i was the youngest one on mass
dancer competing against just
other people and i had obviously no clue
who it was um
but yeah i thought it was i thought it
was really fun um
it was definitely hard for me being on
the show because i had to do school i
couldn't be on set for as long as
everyone else so it was definitely a
challenge um
but i loved every second of it so your
sister just joined uh tick tock
so i'm expecting some like bomb
routines from the two of you like
blowing it up
oh wearing already
we are we are definitely going to do
that soon she's like
still like how do i work this app and
she feels really weird being on it
and i'm like trust me everyone wants you
to be on this app i promise
you i'm expecting epic stuff from you
guys just so you know
just like um and speaking of epic
you put out new music you're working on
an ep come on singer
tell me about this um yeah i mean
i've pretty much just been working on
music this
entire time in quarantine because
obviously
you know i'm in my room and i'm trapped
in my thoughts so that's mainly what
i've been doing
um but yeah i've definitely found a
passion for music
uh pretty recently around like this year
last year and
i'm just so passionate about it
obviously dance is my first love and it
always will be
but i've definitely you know found a
strong passion for music and i'm really
excited to
release everything and for everyone to
see it